[Music]  Eggen Markel and Prince Harry aren't  afraid to show a little PDA the Duchess  of Sussex cheered on her Duke as he  helped lead his team to victory during a  charitable polo match Megan was tasked  with presenting the trophy to the  winning team  here she is congratulating the team  captain with a big hug and kiss on each  cheek but the real prize was reserved  for her hunky hubby we love that these  two are so affectionate per usual they  walked away hand-in-hand  of course Megan looked fashionable for  the event which benefitted the  foundation Harry helped start to support  children affected by HIV in Lesotho and  Botswana in a dark blue chambray midi by  West Gordon for Carolina Herrera he  caught up with her former co-star  Patrick Jay Adams earlier this month he  joked that she's about to rule the  entire world she's coming into her power  in an amazing way and I know that her  and Harry are gonna do incredible things  together